Node.js, GraphQL, Spring Boot, Golang
There'sso many options we have,
as technologists,
to build today's modern APIs.
Fortoday's topic I want to talk about
why you should consider having
API management in your architecture.
Hello, my name is Jamil Spain.
I'm a brand technical specialist
for the Cloud Pak for Integration
in the U.S. Financial Services market,
and when it comes to API management,
I want to focus on three quick areas
that are really my top three when I talk about this topic.
One isinjecting some flexibility in your architecture.
The second is security.
And, more importantly,the analytics
that you're going to get in return,
So, I ll explain more here.
Now, before we getstarted,
I do want to talk and level set
on some common terms that come up
when we talk about API development.
Now, there are two major types
that I like to classify APIs.
The first is serviceAPIs.
Now, I consider service APIs anything that
directly talks to a system of record.
Whether you're an enterprise developer or a
general startup developer, you're making
your own project here,
you always want to protect these APIs.
These are generally your strongest assetshere.
The second type are interaction APIs.
Now actually, anything that's not a service
API, I consider to be an interaction API.
When I start a project out, I generally start with
my service APIs, and then I start development on
these interaction APIs. They may actually call
these service APIs , but let's take a look at that
word. There's one key piece here. That root of
that is interact , so it is generally making some
interaction on top to facilitate some type of
operation that you want to programmaticallydo here.
This is what starts us off at our first
point here: flexibility in the architecture.
Now,  you have consumers who are going to be using
your APIs. In API management, one major concept
is having an API gateway that you have. So,
your users, consumers of your APIs, will
always interact with the API gateway when they
want to consume your APIs.
Now, the job of the actual API gateway
is to perform the interactionlayer,
API layer, there for the most purposes.
Now this is greatly differs if you don't have
API management.
Users, consumers of your APIs, may directly
be talking directly to your APIs,
butthis puts a layer in front.
One of the first things
that gives you the greatest flexibility
is I get to standardize on an interface
you know, denoted and documented through open API
swagger specs of course, through those YAMLs there,
and published in a developer portal so they caneasily
self-service and get on board to usingthe APIs,
but the most important thing is, theydefine,
you know, they're going to get a standard
definition of these APIs.
Now, what actuallyhappens on the other side
for your services that you're running, and I'm
going to do these little database icons here to
imitate the API that you're writing here, it could
actually go to one service or it could be multiple
interactions, invocations to these APIs, and
more of a I've actually done some scatter
gather patterns where I want to hit three services
and build a response that goes back to the user,
the consumer.
Why is that important?
Well, weall know that with
all those technologies that
I mentioned at the beginning,
we want to alwaysbe in a place
that we can feel free to innovate,
refactor, explore new technologies.
Especiallyin this day and time of container architecture
and cloud native, it is very easy to now freeyourself
and try many, many new technologies hereas well.
If you're providing a singular URL to
your users that, without API management, you have
to always be cognizant that, "Hey, I have to always
be able to update my users to the newest thing."
Now, whether that's your new latest startup,
or your new latest enterprise application,
that may be very critical very hard to do in some
perspectives here.
But by having API management in, it gives me the flexibility
to do my owninnovation inside.
The interface that I,
that I give to my users externally doesn't
always have to directly mirror the architecture
that I have inside, so I m free to innovate
there as well.
Second, while this occurs,
I have an opportunity to implement some securityhere.
Each consumer of my APIs when they come up
APIs are generally part of the API management
solution is the APIs have to be published in
some type of usually a self-service developer
portal, and they're going to get assigned a client
ID and secret.
This is a great way ofidentifying and
designating that I know
who is registering their applications and who's
using the APIs there as well.
On top of that,
the second most important thing with security, is
I get to implement an SLA with rate limiting.
Now, this is very, very, very critical because
it gives us a way to kind of conserve the APIs,
the usage of the APIs, that are coming.
I can leverage it to make a service level agreement here
on how much you can use, or if
you want to actually get into monetization,
getting higher tiers, publish a freemium tier, and
then have more higher tiers that you can do.
You can all facilitate this. This is usually built
into every API management solution.
Without  this, you'll have to code and try
to implement these parts yourself.
Lastly, analytics.
I love these because it helps you get to know how
much your APIs are being used.
And once you have users subscribe,
you have this in place, I'll beable to know
who are my most important users of my APIs.
Without API management here you really
don't have a strong indicator of how much people
are using, how many errors you're getting back,
what's the performance, what's the latency.
So,  all these decisions are really hard to - you're
kind of guessing that as well.
Now for you, the organization making the APIs,
one of my bestthings here as well is:
what do we work on?
In today's culture we are a data-driven society,
and this will clearly give us the metrics to say,
we need to devote our time to this particular API
set , because this we have the data to back it up,
that this is what people want, is what they're
using here as well.
So, with this, let's to recap here.
API management is important for the
mere fact of the flexibility it gives you in
your architecture, the security options you have
at your fingertips to implement
and, also, the analytics you get back.
Thank you for your time.
If you have questions, please drop us a line below
and, if you want to see more videos like thisin the future,
please like and subscribe.